pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on en attendait 3 ce fut monsieur
khrouchtchev qui arriva le premier avec
24 heures d'avancé
le premier personnage de l'urss souriez
souriait aux troupes ne souriait aux
bouquets mais monsieur khrouchtchev
était mécontent il venait à moscou de
dévoiler devant les débris d'un avion la
sphère de l'ue de américain abattu à
2000 kilomètres à l'intérieur des
frontières russes
il en avait offert la vue au public
commentait l'objet du raid et son
itinéraire exposer les preuves
retrouvées
l'arsenal du pilote de la seringue
hypodermique prévu pour le suicide au
pistolet à silencieux et témoignages
absolue la photo de powers agents
doubles ou pilote malchanceux
cependant le chancelier adenauer arrivé
en même temps que lui allait
s'entretenir avec le président de gold
est possible rebondissement de ce
problème aussi crucial qu insoluble pour
l'instant le problème allemand dont la
conférence aurait à discuter le
président eisenhower arriver les
oreilles bourdonnantes peut être des
signes incompréhensibles du dernier né
des pique-niques russe lancé depuis
quelques heures et roulant sans
faiblesse sur son orbite petit ballet de
rencontres préalables de gaulle
einsenhower de gaulle macmillan un
public plein de sympathie et des curieux
professionnels bardet d'appareils
guettaient le moindre détail de cette
réunion historique mais monsieur
khrouchtchev devaient bouleverser et les
horaires et les pronostics la sphère de
l'avion espion empoisonné la conférence
elle devenait un duel usa urss
[Musique]
et c'est sur ce départ lourdes suspense
que s'achevaient les trois premières
heures de la rencontre au sommet dans la
plus parfaite incertitude du lendemain
[Musique]
jour j à saint nazaire sur la cale on a
qui jadis le normandy sabbath les
dernières accord autour du plus beau
paquebot le frein
[Musique]
en présence du chef de l'état madame de
gaulle va donner le signal
traditionnelle du lancement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
glissant à la vitesse de 35 km air sur
40 tonnes de graisses le super paquebot
long de 315 mètres a pris contact avec
la mer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ce contact d'une masse de 33 mille
tonnes le navire anjra 55000 avec ses
superstructures ne devait pas passer
inaperçu sur le rivage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le bruit des paquets de chaînes
destinées à freiner sa course voici donc
lancé le nouveau paquebot auquel la
france avec le général de gaulle a fixé
pour mission de la représenter sur
l'océan
capable de transporter deux mille
passagers dès 1962 il sera à la fois le
plus grand et le plus confortable des
transatlantiques moderne
[Applaudissements]
depuis 15 ans l'industrie houillère
française n'a cessé de progresser
les progrès techniques en particulier
ont permis aux charbonnages de suivre le
rythme imposé par les besoins mode et
c'est ainsi que cette espèce de rombeau
a mis fin à l'étiage classique
il s'agit d'un bâti composait des
tensions et de rallonge qui se déplacent
de même sous l'action de vérins
hydrauliques
[Musique]
il suffit de tourner à robin et d'air
comprimé pour le faire avancer selon les
besoins simplification du travail au
fond ce soutènement marchand ouvre une
nouvelle et importante étape de la
modernisation des houillères
le festival de cannes qui s'achève en
beauté a battu le rappel des venets
gilbert bécaud félix marten et
paieraient pradier michel simon et dany
saval au milieu de 75 par l'aide de tous
styles fêtait la dolce vita dans les
vedettes magali noël et nadia gré pressé
vicaut fellini le réalisateur accompagné
de masse 3 ni et d'anouk aimée la plus
belle nuit du festival bel lui qui ne
s'est pas arrêté au spectacle puisque
sitôt après l'assemblée sanaa les
joyeuses vite et aux spaghettis
naturellement le triomphe du film
cependant que le jury présidé par
georges simenon commencé à élaborer le
futur palmarès car c'est tout cela le
festival des vedettes qui sourit un peu
et un jury qui travaille beaucoup
[Musique]
petit drame de famille au japon de
famille ou presque car il s'agit de deux
centrales syndicales rival une grève de
mineurs a donné lieu aux manifestations
classiques c'est-à-dire assez défilé au
pas gymnastique qui sont l'une des
révélations social de l' empire du
soleil levant
mais les deux cortèges s'étant
rencontrés on en vint des deux côtés
d'abord aux mots puis au cou hélas les
images parlent d'elles mêmes
[Musique]
deux mille policiers envoyés pour
rétablir l'ordre se contentèrent de
ramasser les débats
en faisant surface au large du delaware
le tri taux qui est le plus grand sous
marins du monde venait d'accomplir un
exploit sans précédent à bord du
submersible atomique américain
quatre-vingt trois hommes ont fait en
plongée le tour du monde en suivant le
trajet que magellan avait suivi avec ses
caravelle 440 an plus tôt mais le triton
ne mit que 84 jours alors qu'il avait
fallu plus de trois ans à magellan pour
boucler la boucle
[Musique]
à peine le triton avait t-il fait
surface quand l'hélicoptère enlevé
littéralement le commandant du sous
marin ou de nos rangs il ne s'agissait
pas d'un rapt particulièrement audacieux
mais d'une initiative de la maison
blanche où le président des états unis
n'avaient pas voulu perdre une minute
pour récompenser le capitaine edward
beach son ancien conseiller navale
[Musique]
médaille présidentielle
et félicitations conjugales
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant ce temps à new london les
membres de l'équipage retrouver leurs
familles huit d'entre eux apprenait
qu'il était devenu père 84 jours
d'absence que voulez vous ça compte
le
[Musique]
au générique du film à suspense de
colombes le prince rainier supporter
détendu de l'as monaco la princesse
grace et monsieur antoine pinay l'ancien
ministre des finances supporter très
décontracté lui aussi de l' as
st-etienne avant le deuxième acte de la
finale de la coupe de france
le deuxième acte débute et saint-etienne
maillot foncé qui a fourni jusqu'à
présent le meilleur football attaque par
rené fériés petit ballet de
l'avant-centre liront qui donne le
frisson à son altesse sérénissime plus
massive plus lourdes sont les contre
attaques de monaco voici les demies et
les avants d'un gars par action le sort
de la partie semble se jouer sur cette
attaque est relié droit numéro 7 et ludo
le 2000e numéro 4 des bords tous leurs
adversaires
non il en reste et 1 le gardien de but
claude à
et saint-etienne reprend le contrôle du
jeu un jeu beaucoup plus liées plus
élégant que celui des monégasques
finalement c'est saint-etienne qui prend
l'avantagé au bon moment c'est etienne
va gagner il reste cinq minutes à jouer
dans ses ministres des finances marque
un point sur la famille princière de
monaco et la princesse grace qui a déjà
joué sous la direction d'alfred
hitchcock n'est pas inquiété la quant à
rebondissements elle avait raison but
pour monaco
tout est remise en question
prolongations difficile à supporter
quand on est nerveux
saint-etienne donnent des signes de
lassitude
les spectateurs aussi
[Applaudissements]
troisième but pour monaco qui revient de
loin
[Applaudissements]
joie dans le camp monégasque fatigue
d'un supporter qui commence à trouver le
temps long
[Applaudissements]
et voilà 4 à 2 c'était bien cela le
suspense les beaux yeux de la princesse
grace valait bien ce petit coup du
destin bonnacois gagné la coupe de
france que monsieur roger frey remettent
à raymond kaelbel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]